alors comment faire pour éviter que les
opérateurs ne s'entendent entre eux
faut-il accentuer les contrôles les
opérateurs sous surveillance c'est la
question du 13h
et pour y répondre nous retrouvons luc
chatel député ump de haute marne en
direct de reims luc chatel vous entendez
bonjour alors comme les associations de
consommateurs on l'a vu dans le
reportage vous êtes très mobilisée pour
en faveur des consommateurs est ce que
vous diriez vous aussi qu'il serait
après tout légitime que les
consommateurs qui ont été lésés dans
cette affaire touche une partie de
l'amendé soit indemnisé
absolument le seul arrêt qu'a rendu la
cour d'appel ce matin et bien sûr une
bonne nouvelle ça vexe et la plus grande
amende jamais constatée dans le domaine
de la concurrence en france l'une des
dix plus importantes au niveau mondial
c'est une satisfaction pour tous les
citoyens que nous sommes que des
pratiques illicites soient sanctionnés
en même temps c'est une réelle
frustration pour les consommateurs que
nous sommes parce que pas un centime de
cette amende n'ira indemniser les
consommateurs qui ont été lésés par ces
pratiques anticoncurrentielles et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je me bats au
côté des associations de consommateurs
que vous avez cités pour que nous
mettions en place en france qu'on
appelle des recours collectifs
consommateurs
action absolument et beaucoup d'autres
pays notamment en europe et vous savez
qu'en février prochain nous aurons à
l'assemblée nationale un projet de loi
sur la consommation ou nous débattrons
de cette question mais je crois que
c'est indispensable que les
consommateurs plus obtenir réparation
des préjudices qu'ils subissent vous
revenir à la téléphonie mobile vous vous
estimez que aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
vraiment de concurrence entre opérateurs
n'ont en france la concurrence est
complètement fictive puisque je rappelle
que les trois opérateurs historiques ont
plus de 96 % du marché je rappelle que
en moins de deux ans il n'y a que huit
cent mille abonnés sur 50 millions qui
ont changé d'opérateur alors pourquoi
parce que tout ça le mans il faut deux à
trois mois aujourd'hui pour changer
d'opérateur en tout en conservant le
même numéro donc on voit on met un petit
peu partout des freins pour pour changer
et on sait bien que la concurrence c'est
bon pour le consommateur et puis
deuxième élément vous savez il ya ces
fameuses durée d'engagement et matta
kabal un engagement minimal obligatoire
absolument c'est à dire que beaucoup
d'opérateurs font des offres
promotionnelles qui peuvent paraître
intéressante on vous dit bah tiens je
vous offre le portable mais en
contrepartie vous signez pour 24 mois et
aujourd'hui vous avez 75% des
consommateurs qui sont liés avec des
offres de durée d'engagement ce qui fait
qu'en fait la concurrence ne joue qu'une
fois tous les deux ans donc je
m'efforcerai dans le cadre de la loi
consommation dont je serai le rapporteur
de faire voter des amendements qui
permettront de faire jouer davantage la
concurrence dans notre pays parce que il
faut que le budget de téléphonie mobile
des ménages diminuent ça a été le cas
dans la plupart des grands pays
européens moins de 30% ces dernières
années ça n'est pas le cas en france par
le parce que la concurrence ne joue pas
assez merci beaucoup pour ces précisions
luc chatel merci d'avoir été avec nous
en direct de rein